in your childlike
open-minded excitement and approach to
science
you're i think to anyone listening to
this are truly inspiring
i mean the question i think is useful to
ask
is by way of advice for young people a
lot of young people
listen to this whether from all over the
world
and teenagers undergraduate students
even graduate students even be like
even young faculty even older faculty
they're all young at heart like there's
many
young hearts you have advice for bullets
focus on
the traditionally defined sort of uh
young folks like undergraduate do you
have advice
to give to young people like that today
about
life maybe in general maybe a life of
curiosity in the sciences
definitely um well first i should
confess that i enjoy working with young
people much more than with senor
and the reason is they don't carry a
baggage of prejudice
yes they're not so self-centered they're
open to exploration
uh my advice i mean one of the lessons
that
took me a while to learn and i should
say
i i lost important opportunities as a
result of that so that i would
regard it as a mistake on my behalf
was to believe experts so quote unquote
so um on a number of occasions i would
come up with an original idea
and then suggest it to an expert someone
that works in the same field for a while
and the expert will dismiss it most of
the time because it's new
and was not explored not because of the
merit
and then what happened to me several
times is that
someone else would listen to the
conversation or would hear me suggesting
it
and i would give up because the expert
said no
and then that someone else you know
would
develop it so that it becomes the
hottest thing in this field
and it hap you know once it happened to
me multiple times
i then realized the hell with the
experts
they don't know what they're talking
about they're just repeating them yes
they don't think creatively
they are being threatened by innovation
okay and it's the natural reaction of
someone that cares about
their ego more than about the matter
that we are discussing and so i said i
would not i don't care how many likes i
have on twitter
i don't care whether the experts say one
thing or another i will basically
exercise my judgment
yes and do the best i can you know turns
out that i'm wrong
i made a mistake you know that's part of
the of the
scientific endeavor you know and uh it
took me a while to recognize that and it
was a lot of wasted opportunities so
to the young people i would recommend
don't listen
to experts carve your own path
now of course you will be wrong you
should learn from experience
just like kids do but do it yourself
you